everyone wants to travel doesn't matter
if you have a disability or not
disabilities are not on people are on
the barriers and if we eliminate
barriers disabilities are not an issue
anymore if you see someone in Machu
Picchu in a wheelchair you say oh like
everything is possible right my name is
Alvaro
and I'm the co-founder of will the world
will the world is an online platform for
people with disabilities to find and
book accessible trips when I was 18 I
was on a car accident I was on the
backseat and I broke my neck at the
level c5 since that moment I have a
quadriplegia when you have had tragic
instance like that one it's hard to
accept it of course is something that I
never thought that it would happen to me
my dream since I kid was to explore
torres del paine in a national park in
the chilean side of patagonia chile is
my country but for years i thought that
this would be impossible nobody else in
a wheelchair had done it before with my
friend Camila we found online a special
hiking wheelchair that would allow us to
do this trip we film a low-cost
documentary that went viral online and
then thousands of people reach out to us
saying oh this is so cool when I repeat
this trip so we started organizing this
trip to other people and then we decided
to co-found will the world some of the
experiences that we offer is scuba
diving in Easter Island subliming
adventure in Costa Rica the visit to
Machu Picchu the one of the most magical
places in the world places like Hawaii
Patagonia waka can Mexico places that
people never thought that they would be
able to travel to these places we're
trying to what anyone would do in these
travel destinations also offer it for
people with mobility constraints
[Music]
there's 1 billion people in the world
that has some sort of disability so many
people that never thought that travel
would be a thing for them so far in less
than 2 years more than 700 people has
been impacted because of will the world
it makes me feel like really happy that
is more than just allowing people to
travel is allowing people to live I love
to visit new places and to travel and to
get in touch with new people it makes me
feel alive for many years I limited
myself to that kind of experiences and
realizing that it's possible for me that
I can do it it makes me feel so alive
and happy to be living
you
[Music]